and uh here we go yes so here we go
uh blitz chess magnus carson is famous
for this he's been
world champion several times at blitz so
he's a big favorite but
um daniel dubois he's shown today he's
not to be messed with and we see a
repeat
so far of their second rapid game from
today the players are heading straight
down
playing the same moves uh magnus carson
remember he lost that game but he got a
good position out of the opening so
magnus carlsen
repeating the exact same opening but
this time daniel dubois plays a
different move
pushing his pawn in the middle daniel
dubov changing things up
surprising his opponent with a new move
compared to what they played
a bit earlier today and it looks like
daniel dubois he's done his research in
that break
and it's still a very unusual move so
magnus
might have been taken by surprise yes
and magnus might be taken by surprise
but there's no time
to be surprised in these blitz games
even if your opponent shocks you with a
move
you just have to keep reacting yeah you
have to make sure you rely on that
adrenaline
even and okay we have seen a trade of
pawns in the center of black's knight
now
nicely centralized will we see magnus
carson capture that night with his
bishop
will we see him defend a pawn that's
attacked on that left side
magnus behind on the clock quite
significantly at this early
stage almost a minute down this early on
um
the one fear for magnus carson is that
in blitz chess you don't have time to
react and
daniel dubois is well he's shown us
today
he will play some surprising moves he
will shock magnus at some point
magnus needs to keep time in order to
react to those surprises and
magnus burning a huge amount of time on
this one move right now
and uh we heard irwin talk about it the
the difficulty for for a niche gear to
transition from classical chess in just
a few days to rapid chess
they had 20 minutes now to transition
from rapid
to blitz is that difficult it is
difficult um
blitz it's all about that focus all
about the adrenaline all about
just kind of building up that rhythm to
play quickly in the differences in rapid
chess in these 15 minutes games we've
been seeing
sometimes the players they can afford to
take a time out to think for six seven
minutes on one move
if it's a really critical moment but in
blitzchess it's hard
to know exactly when you can take that
timeout and hear magnus he spent a
minute and a half on this move
this early in the game it's it looks
like he hasn't found that rhythm yet he
hasn't adapted the world champion
yeah it's a little bit impractical isn't
it uh
this isn't a critical position so to
speak much better to leave that time for
later on
um he's frozen i mean he spent nearly
look he's talking to himself magnus
magnus carson is talking to himself
right now and he finally
makes a move after two minutes and it's
just an innocent pawn move
he could have played that move instantly
without thinking but magnus spending
two minutes on a move and it's not a
good one uh
daniel dubois now surprised we see him
lean back he can take a pawn black can
grab a pawn with his knight
i'm not sure he will but it's there the
option's there uh yeah the options there
for the taking
but we do know duboff doesn't like to
grab pawns you know we kind of joked a
little bit about
it he'd much rather sacrifice upon
for activity um okay
so uh are we expecting uh duboff to
actually
i think take that step forward dubov he
could capture a point with his knight
right now but i would expect to see him
maybe improve his rook or improve his
light squared bishop
um for black um he just needs to make a
move quickly he needs to capitalize on
the fact that magnus carson throws there
for two minutes
magnus frustrated with himself um if
dubois plays okay he does capture that
pawn um
magnus brings his queen across one
square so now white's queen eyeing up
the black knight and eyeing up the pawn
in the middle of the board
can uh can do both use some tactics to
keep that knight
wedged there and on its square yes i
think daniel dubov
has a trick in this position and there
we go he brings his knight to the middle
if white's queen now gets greedy and
takes a black knight
the other black knight will drop itself
down into the middle of the board
forking the king and the queen a family
fork
a royal fork even uh winning the white
queen magnus castle he's blunted his
queen twice
in the bash so far he won't do it for a
third time but now we see white win his
pawn back
in the middle of the board level
material again but magnus carson he's
down
one minute on the clock those black
knights look super well placed right now
super active
and you can just see those black black
knights are coming forward like there's
no tomorrow
so one of the knights has moved in to
give a check to the king
and i think it's going to be goodbye to
the bishop pair
and uh wow whoa wow wow okay i'm just
had a look at the bar and the bar just
really swung in black's favor
i'm trying to work out what is happening
here daniel dubois has a winning move
right now
um it's not obvious though it's very
difficult to see especially in blitz
chess with not much time black could
actually use his bishop
drop it all the way down and capture a
pawn sacrifice a bishop
this is daniel dubos style if anyone can
find it he can but that looks like a
winning move right now
yeah purely because it would explode the
position uh explode the shelter in front
of white's king
and blacks knights they've been dancing
around but they're positioned perfectly
to kind of box in white's king and join
the attack a bit later on um it's not an
obvious move i would
wouldn't be surprised if daniel dubov
goes for something a bit more simple but
maybe magnus carson we see him raise his
eyebrows
maybe he's just spotted that um this one
i mean he knows his position is
promising but there's so much choice
so many options and it is blitz chess
not much time it is blitz chest and we
also you know
we see the bar move up and down and so
therefore we can make a guess
oh yeah well hang on a second now the
time is right it is
we can go for it and sacrifice a piece
open lines
debuff doesn't actually see the bar so
he has to figure it out by himself
and maybe he doesn't sense that the
moment is now
um but that is one beautiful move
yeah it's not an easy move to play i
mean it's such a high pressure situation
when you're facing the world champion
when you've got the black pieces it's
not an easy uh
thing to sacrifice a piece for not
immediate um kind of obvious
compensation
i reckon i knew it
i was fantastically spotted by daniel
dubov he found a move that was not
obvious at
all no and uh but okay the world
champion magnus carlsen is on the ropes
yeah he's given up a piece i mean we did
say if anyone could find it duboffcan he
loves to sacrifice it's his first
instinct
essentially and the whole idea if white
plays pawn takes bishop right now
black will actually capture white's
light squared bishop and then bring the
black queen into the middle of the board
giving check to the white king
and this would actually be devastating
uh daniel dubov he found that movie he
spent time at the right moment daniel
duboff he spent a minute and a half
there
uh on a critical moment he he just felt
his instincts told him there was a win
magnus carlton wasted two minutes
earlier on a useless move so that i
think dubois is using his time
but this is a tight rope because well
duboff
has to capture that bishop and he has
found it
wow because anything else would have
lost him the game so uh yeah
now now magnus carlsen decided there was
no time to capture that black knight he
captured the one in the middle of the
board now black's queen drops herself
into the center as well
giving check to the white king black now
any time he wants complain knight takes
rook in the corner on that left-hand
corner black
knight can capture that rook but dubose
biding his time
uh white's king is under attack white
has to decide a huge decision for magnus
carlsen do you just block
that check with a pawn do you move your
king up one square do you trade queens
either way it looks like dubov is going
to snap off that white rook in the
corner
black's to be up on material black will
have an extra rook
for a bishop but the problem is the
danger is for duboff the black knight
will be trapped in the corner it might
take a while to relocate
later on so still in the balance despite
it looking good for duboff
and magnus carlsen has not reacted
physically to this moving his king here
yep moving the king he still senses
there's a chance remember yeah as your
man consent
the players they don't know the
evaluation magnus he's looking for the
positives in the position
he can't take 30 seconds just beating
himself up for missing this idea
he needs to just hope for the best play
for tricks there's still a chance
black's knight will be offside next move
daniel dubo thinking now going down to
two minutes daniel duvall
yeah this is not uh practical by daniel
de novo
he has to take the knight that was the
move and you can see
magnus is moves the bishop to attack
that knight but not just that the bishop
is
also having some discovered potential
against
the black left uh right side of the
board that pawn in front of the king
and the bar is reacting here david yep
um it may be not the most accurate move
by daniel dubois but probably the most
human move so we can't fault him
too much for that one black's brought
his rook across to the center pinning
white's tonight white's knight now
cannot move because the queen is behind
it black's rook would take the white
queen but
maybe daniel dubois should have used the
other rook because now black's other
rook the one next to the black king is
actually trapped it's getting in the way
of things a bit and magnus carson not
caring about that black knight in the
corner
just going for the attack magnus knows
it's his best chance now
to counter attack against the black king
which has no defenders around it exactly
and with the clocks ticking down
what really matters is to have the
initiative and to have the attack
because it's very very difficult to
defend and i really like
magnus's last move lining up that rook
on an open line
and look how it points towards that pawn
yeah the pawn in front of the black king
there not feeling comfortable at all
eyed up by the white rook also
potentially idot by the white bishop
um it's looking difficult for now for
daniel dubois suddenly
he's on the back foot he's material up
but remember he prefers to be material
down but with the attack
this time roles have reversed magnus
carlsen is the one
behind on points but with a potential
attack and
daniel dubois he attacks the white
knight the white knight cannot move is
still pinned
and there's only one move now to escape
from that pin
and magnus has found it he has moved the
queen look at the rook and the queen
there
are lined up on that line and now white
is threatening checkmate now there's
there is absolutely no chance that
dubois will actually miss his checkmate
so we are expecting him to defend
there's only one move for black to
survive now and it's not obvious do both
will hate to play this move okay he has
found it
black moving the pawn in front of his
king but look how airy look how loose
the black king's position feels uh i
mean yeah
it's so open right now black's king
magnus carson he needs to find a way to
kind of snake the white queen in yeah
attack the black king yeah exactly i
mean that's that's the move that comes
to my mind just
step the queen one square diagonally
and then we can start threatening checks
because the game is just too uh
wild i mean it's crazy right now why
magnus carlsen i think he can force a
draw by bringing his queen up
trying to threaten to check the black
king he's played it he's gone for it now
black
should play probably rook takes knight
and
if white checks with the white queen it
only checks white's only attacking with
one piece but black has to get rid of
the knight
before the knight joins the attack um
then daniel dubois will be safe but
magnus castle could maybe force a draw
um daniel dubois his clock is ticking
under 30 seconds now he
has to make sure he can't uh allow
a mating attack against the black king
he has to capture that knight now with a
pawn or with the rook
to survive you know he has to adapt from
the mind frame that maybe he was winning
before oh
david huge blunder absolutely he did not
adjust he thought he was still winning
and so he rejected the draw and oh my
god
so a huge huge blunder so david take us
through those for those moves
yep so daniel dubois he didn't allow
that draw he didn't allow the perpetual
check he wanted to win
but now white's knight has suddenly gone
up and won one of black's rooks
and suddenly black's position is just
falling apart black's knight as well it
was so good but it's offside it's not
playing a part in this game
the computer evaluation we see shoots up
for white finally catching up with the
play
black's king is too open white's got an
attack temporarily material ahead as
well
um suddenly magnus carlsen is turning on
the fire i mean he's
he's he's just worked his way through
these complications through this maze
perfectly well white has emerged with an
extra knight that knight will decide the
game
yeah and we see the queen gives check
black's king hiding away in the corner
but essentially white's attacking now
with an extra piece he's got a knight
black's got a couple of pawns but those
pawns are irrelevant
hundred percent yeah 100 likes
and you can just see and it's finished
yep magnus carlson getting a win here
yeah white giving check about to win the
black rook about to give checkmate and
daniel dubois he just self-destructed
he panicked and blundered magnus gulstan
taking it home
spectacular at the end